hello folks and welcome to today's
webinar on Farm composting fundamentals
with Dr Robert rink I'm Linda bson
brolis of the institute for local
self-reliance composting for Community
initiative and will be your hosts for
this com uh webinar
series a quick shout out to a couple of
my issr colleagues who are helping with
the series uh Sophia Jones will be
providing technical support throughout
this webinar and libertelli is a
talented artist who is creating
beautiful graphics for a composting
initiative including this image so thank
you for both thank you both for your
help uh for those of you that aren't
familiar with our work issrs composting
for Community initiative is advancing
composting to reduce waste enhance local
soils create Community Development
opportunities and protect the climate
our focus is to catalyze distributed
food waste composting options that
include home community and on Farm
scales we work to promote locally based
composting in a number of different
ways we convene a national Community
composter Coalition and host networking
and knowledge sharing opportunities such
as our cultivating Community composting
forums we work one-on-one with
communities through technical assistance
and policy support we produce reports
and
infographics we host regular webinars
and a podcast as well as a map that
showcases initiatives around the country
and policies and programs that are
advancing composting at this
scale we also offer Technical Training
through our neighborhood soil Rebuilders
composter training program and for
anyone that's interested in more
training we'll be releasing a self-paced
online community composting 101 101
course later this fall this course
covers composting fundamentals and the
ins and outs of starting a
community-based composing initiative so
stay stay
tuned you can find all of these
resources and more on our website if you
go to il.org
composting you'll see a composting
resources drop- down menu on the right
hand side of the screen and from there
you can select reports podcasts webinars
and
more so back to this webinar series uh
this series is being brought to you
through our involvement with the million
acre challenge which you'll be hearing
more about in a
moment uh but our belief is that we can
only achieve a regenerative food system
if the nutrients from our food scraps
and other organic materials are cycled
back into our soils and farmers and
other folks that care for the soil are
ideal stewards of this process there are
many other benefits of composting and
compost use which is exactly what the
series will
explore as you can see here this is the
first of the series in which Dr Robert
rink will cover the variety of methods
and key considerations for establishing
accomplishing site on a farm next up on
September 14th we'll hear from Ellen
polishuk who was a farmer at pic
Vegetable Farms in Virginia for 25 years
she'll discuss integrating composting
into your farming business and how to
use it as a tool for profit and growth
check out the rest of the lineup here
and on our
website but now let's get to know each
other a little bit with some interactive
polls so you'll be able to participate
in the poll by going to the goto webinar
control panel should be on your
screen so first question where are you
participating
from Northeastern us Southern us
Midwestern us Western us or outside of
the
US give you all just a few more
seconds all right let's see the
results so primarily Northeastern us but
a pretty good spr
even a few folks from outside of the US
so thanks for joining
us next
question are you
composting yes you're already composting
no but you're interested in starting no
you're interested in supporting others
in composting or
other all right just a couple more
seconds
seconds so large majority are already
composting awesome welcome uh hopefully
we'll be providing you some great info
to improve your composting and for those
of you that have not started yet uh
hopefully we'll be giving you some
inspiration to do
so last question for
now what best describes your affiliation
and I'm sorry they only give you five
options so I had to condense some of the
options but are you a farmer a composter
a farm service provider and then either
a researcher government or
nonprofit uh person and then other
business or
other right just a couple more seconds
all right let's check out the
results so a good chunk are farmers
welcome but there's also a lot of either
researcher government or
nonprofit and a few other composters and
other business so welcome to
everyone head back to
my presentation
all righty
okay so uh at this point I would love to
hand things over to my colleague at the
million acre challenge Amanda Cather who
is the Project Director of the million
acre
challenge so am Amanda if you're on the
line you can unmute
yourself okay can you hear me yes we can
okay thank you Linda very much um yes as
Linda said my name is Amanda cther and
I'm the Project Director for the million
acre challenge we are uh a collaborative
project of five six founding partners
and many more collaborators and Farmers
working to bring 1 million Acres of
healthy soils to the ches Peak region
and to help catalyze the national
movement towards regenerative
agriculture and we are very grateful to
be able to help sponsor this Workshop
series with ilsr who is one of those six
founding partners
uh we at the million acre challenge work
towards regenerative agriculture using a
combination of five levers which are
represented in our five working groups
and you can see them here on this slide
um farmer engagement scientific research
creating of business case for
regeneration working on State and local
policy and also participating in U
National discussions about state and
local policy and creating consumer
demand for regenerative agriculture via
public Outreach so and of course as all
of you know because you're here today on
Farm composting is deeply important and
woven through all of these layers um and
these working groups with the potential
to increase Farm profitability provide
significant ecosystem services including
potentially reductions in greenhouse gas
emissions and contribute to farm
resilience in the face of a changing
climate which we feel every single day
at least on my farm um so as you all
know composting this is our mission uh
and our vision for the million acre
Challenge and composting is both
critically important to this mission and
vision and also scientifically and
technically complex which is why the
million acre challenge partners are so
excited to be a part of the series
bringing together Regional and National
experts on on Farm composting um I would
encourage you to find out more about the
million-acre challenge on the web at
million-acre challenge.org or on our
social media feeds we'd love to connect
with all of you um but for now I think
we should get on with what you came for
oh this these are our team our six
founding partners and we're grateful to
all of them for their support today and
always and yeah let's get on with the
webinar awesome thanks
Amanda all right so uh before we begin
our Feature Presentation just a few
house housekeeping notes um everyone is
in listen only mode um we should have
about 20 or so minutes at the end of the
webinar for questions but go ahead and
enter your questions as they come up
into the go-to webinar control panel box
on your screen we'll be monitoring them
there um this webinar is being recorded
and a copy will be sent to you as a
registrant of the webinar um there's
also a handout of the presentation
available um as an
attachment um if you are a farmer who
was not who could not the uh discount
code and end up ended up paying for the
webinar please let us know either in the
chat here or by emailing us and we will
uh get you refunded so just let us know
but without further Ado um it is my
pleasure to introduce our speaker uh Dr
Robert rink has been researching and
teaching about processing of
agricultural and other organic materials
for over 30 years he's an
internationally renowned expert who has
authored numerous Publications including
the original on Farm composting handbook
and its pending sequel the composting
handbook he is an agricultural engineer
and is a regular instructor for
composting training schools and
workshops both nationally and
internationally so without further Ado
take it away Dr
rank oh thank you Linda uh let me share
my webcam briefly know you don't want to
look at me the whole time but that's
what I look like I just wanted to show
you that I'm here I'm not a robot or
chicken or Linda changing her voice um
and I'm very happy to be here um I
appreciate the opportunity to uh talk
about on Farm composting because I think
it's important so let me get rid of
myself and start showing you my slides
which are great deal more
interesting okay get started everybody
see that and hear me didn't that y looks
good sounds good okay great thanks so um
I'm going to talk about the fundamentals
of on composting and composting
generally um we have an hour that's not
a lot of time to cover the Waterfront so
I'm going to do this uh more or less
best as I can um I took a look at your
questions that you put in ahead of time
I think that will ask I will answer a
bunch of those um and some I will only
touch upon and then others uh you'll
have to wait for the other webinar
speakers who will address them in a bit
more detail but uh I'll be glad to
answer questions at the end to get into
more detail as
needed okay so uh what am I going to be
talking about today uh why on Farm
composting matters I'll give a brief
overview of the process and mostly by
example of what uh other Farms have done
show you the methods and equipments
involved in composting again it's just a
sampling given the time we have um we'll
talk about site requirements and en
environmental factors but here's where
the more or less comes in I'll be
spending more time on the the methods
and Equipment then I will be on site
requirements and environmental
factors okay what I won't be talking
about in much depth at all is composting
farmw test ities for vermac composting
on
Farm uh Community Based
composting and the compost how to use it
um how to make the quality you want how
to sell it and won't be getting much
into economics but again I'll be glad to
answer questions at the end and in
general details and specifics will be
missing because of the time but if
you're interested in at least three of
those topics uh composting animal
mortality Community scale composting and
Verma composting there are some great
references out there for you to gain
more
information um the one on the upper
leftand side is available from the
online from the cor Cornell Waste
Management Institute I think it's free
and the other two are books uh well
worth the investment and you'll be
hearing from James mcqueeny later on in
the program and then of course this has
been my big project is taking the on for
composing handbook expand in it and
updating it and um creating a new
handbook and this is just about done uh
the chapters are with the publisher they
think they could get it out by the end
of the year let's have our fingers
crossed um especially Before Christmas
I'm sure would make a great
Christmas um and that's the introduction
so what does composting
do in a nutshell basic basically
composting takes Raw Feed stocks like
this and many other types of feed stocks
these happen to be called potatoes from
um a farm in um Central
Washington and turns it into this from
something that's difficult to handle
doesn't have an immediate use to
something that's a lot more that's
easier to handle and does have a good
use so this compost being spread here
was made from
these very same well not the very same
but made from cold potatoes also and
other Packing Shed PS uh along with
dairy minor to become an input for this
particular
farm so why does on Farm composting
matter
well basically because composting and
compost matter they play important roles
not only in agriculture but in society
General and
composting and compost on
farms um Farms are an exellent place for
both so if we can take do a lot of the
composting on farms and Farms can accept
a lot of the compost that's
made um we are solving a great number of
problems so on Farm composting matters a
lot because compost and
compost uh the first reason the probably
the most important reason that
composting matters is that is the
compost which can greatly improve soils
and improve plant Health again you're
going to get a another uh womin RC U
presentation on this so I'm not going go
in any depth but in a picture this is
what composting does for the
soil and in words from the same um from
Dr Gan um these are some of the benefits
of compost to soils and
plants particularly on farms composting
also has a place in manure management
increasingly um Farmers have uh some
difficulty handling manur as animal
numbers increase and land doesn't
necessarily increase along with it um
it's easy to get in a situation where
there's too many nutrients for the
farm uh manure can be difficult to
handle um it has more volume more weight
more water than compost and that could
equate to more trips to distant fields
to apply it uh in an agronomic
manner um whereas compost stores well it
doesn't have to be applied right away uh
and it's exportable and it's exportable
because it handles easily and therefore
more people want it or more people
willing to take it from the farm and
even people willing to pay for it so
potentially depending upon the farm
situation um compost can can be a
benefit to minor
man okay and then there's the potential
for added Revenue to the
mar Revenue can come from uh making
compost by selling the compost that's
made or by being paid to take uh waste
and residu from off the farm so this
picture shows both this is not a farm
this is a company that takes advantage
of both of those revenue streams they
sell compost they charge for bring in
inred in farm situations that could be
difficult um in some jurisdictions if
you do either of these on the farm that
is sell compost made from waste from off
the form or sell compost at all or
taking off Farm waste uh that
jurisdiction may say well you're no
longer Farm that's not always the case
depends upon the state in particular in
some cases you could do both and still
retain uh your your farm
classification in other cases uh you
could do one or the other better not
both and that's usually the common case
so you can sell
compost um from feed stocks that you
collect on the farm or even off farm
feed stocks and you're still Farm or you
can bring in green waste but not sell
the compost um and you'd be still a farm
usually it's the bringing in off Farm
materials that's a little more allowed
and where the revenues U are more easily
captured in this case it takes a pretty
good effort sometimes to
Sol um and bringing in off Farm waste um
there were a lot of people who might be
looking for a home for their waste and
residues uh and farms are a good place
to bring it it just brings some
cautions and we'll talk about that
one of the reasons that route is a
little easier is because um we recognize
that it's not so easy to get rid of
waste anymore particularly organic waste
don't want to put them in Nill and a
good number of states the slides from my
colleague Matt cotton good number of
states uh starting 40 years ago started
Banning art trimmings from lfi that's
when we had a landfill crisis and more
recently um a number states are
beginning to ban uh Food wids they'll
call it or Organics generally New York
State being the most recent to um to
implement a Statewide ban uh for food
and that presents
opportunities uh for Farm to Tak in
these materials and pay get paid to do
that um so you know
food is the new trend and it's because
of its impact on climate change so when
food is brought to the landfill even
with a landfill with a a um methane
collection system it still makes methane
and that methane escapes and that's
because food breaks down so quickly at
the landfill face um it it emits its
methane
before methane clutch system has a
effect has chance to to start collecting
and methane is a poent greenhouse and
thirdly there's better options for food
than than throwing it l first being um
try to make use of it uh as food for
people and then food the animals and
then finally can be composted or sent an
analytic
digestion but all of those are better
than land so the push to start taking
food waste out of the landfill though is
mostly due to climate
change and then compost has some
benefits as far as uh cration sticking
to the climate change theme um this
slide is from uh Jeff Greek I think I
saw Jeff's name on on the list um so
this is where compost have been used on
rangeland or pasture in uh Marin County
in
California and uh the researcher has
shown some pretty good benefits so
here's just an
example um oh let me go back that's the
previous Slide the squares indicate
where cows are grazing on this land that
they receive compost and they seem to be
preferentially grazing on those plots
where composts was uh used versus um the
rest of the pasture lamb where was no
compos um but more directly this is a
slide of the soil organic
matter uh several years after a single
application of compost was made so the
red bars are are the plots that had
compost and you can see they generally
show pyur oranic matter compared to
control plots which didn't receive
compost but the big story here is that
this is not an annual application of
compost that that the soil organic
matter is responding to but a single
application that happened in two 2008 so
that one application has many years of
impact and this project is still going
on
uh so sticking with the climate change
theme um another colleague of mine uh
Jane Gilbert led a team that looked that
tried to put a number on the V carbon
sequestration value of compost alone
it's available in this publication from
the iswa again I think that's free uh
and they placed a value on it just for
carbon sequestration of
$59 per fresh ton of compost that's of
the compost and not of the waste meaning
it's not a Dr kind of compost
that's there's some value there so all
good great unfund composting will great
what's the
downside well it takes work it takes
work it takes time you got to put money
into it you need space to do it
investment in equipment investment in
land maybe investment in
controls um so it's not free and the
hope is that it'll pay for itself either
in uh the value of the compost or the
service you provide um but it does take
an
effort and then there also the hassles
related to mostly odors okay um so this
is a sign I came across uh where a
compost was trying to expand a farm
composter uh into new land and there was
lots of
neighborhood opposition to that mostly
because there had been odor issues
before um so composting isn't welcome by
everyone it's generally welcom by
everyone until it get comes to your
neighborhood and then there's an issue
these things are controllable um I
shouldn't say controllable these things
can be made better by a number of
practices that composters can do
including um becoming more active
participating in the
neighborhood um but this is one of the
things that any composter May face even
on a farm but the sign's wrong sign
should say this say yes composting and
it is farming it's very compatible with
farming it's consistent with farming in
fact I would even argue that composting
is inherently farming um by its nature
because you're you're using natural
processes to produce a
product um that and you're husbanding
microorganisms to do that
and um it's a radical idea but I would
suggest yes if you're composting you're
automatically
F so um that's the why let's look at the
how the composting process Le part of
the house I'm going to go through this
fairly quickly uh because a lot of you
are composters already I know much of
this uh these are the ins and outs of
the composting process the direction of
the Arrow show whether it's an in or out
basically what we put in are feed stocks
the microorganisms are there although
some people add special microorganisms
to do that the oxygen comes in on its
own um although again in some cases they
have to make an effort to do that and
the water is well and the outputs are
water vapor carbon dioxide and heat all
good things and then there are some bad
things odors and other gases that people
might object check to but the main
output is complex which is a value added
product of the feed stocks that
go and here's the trend of a compost uh
a composting process okay many of you
have seen this graph or something like
it temperature tells a story of what's
going on during compost and temperature
does that by by the fact that it's a
direct result of the decomposition
that's taking place of the microbes
action so as heat is released from
decomposition temperature goes up
and uh accumulates and heats up the pile
and it it basically reflects how much
heat is being
generated okay so there's several stages
there's this accelerating stage in the
begin beginning when temperature heats
up quickly this long stage um hot hot
and Rapid composting where we spend most
of our time um and then a final stage
where compost cures and
matures and and that's reflected by the
lower temperatures going on there's a
few other temperatures to uh take note
of one is the the the point at which a
mesophilic process turns into a
thermophilic process this is not a very
important point it's just an academic
matter really and it's not it's not a
fixed Point anyway the microorganism
cell don't see this line and don't know
where it happens uh it's just that
thermophilic microorganisms can um
withstand higher temperatures and they
do most of the work through most of the
composting process and mesophilic micro
don't they can play different
roles um so mesophilic for example
mesophilic
microorganisms uh are more active in
that curing and maturing stage and
they're mesophilic some mesophilic
organisms are the ones that turn ammonia
into nitrite and nitrate so that
transformation happens
basically we're in a thermic for the
w a more important line is this one and
that's the pathogen
threshold um or at least that's the
pathogen the standard pathogen thres
regulations
often dictate that pathogens and wheat
seeds have to be killed depending upon
the feed stocks and the situation you
have to make sure you've followed
pathogen reduction process and in the US
we call that
uh process to
further process to further reduce
pathogens
PP uh outside of the us we may just call
it sanitization or
or or homogeneization
um but it generally happens it's
generally defined at this 55 degre
Celsius or 100 which is 101 degrees
fahren at this point so normally the
regulations say when they apply is that
have to hold the composting materials
above that temperature for a certain
amount of time for static processes and
processes that are contained in the
vessel that's 55 degrees C uh for three
days uh for windr which are smaller have
a more a larger surface area and they
get turned it's actually 15 degrees and
it has to be turned five times within
that time span within that 15 degre
times or it has to be turned five
times and uh and during the five times
it stays above 55 de now outside of the
us some regulations require have raised
this passage threshold to 60 degrees and
even 65 degrees in some places which can
be a challenge depending upon the but
basically is 505 so that's an important
one and that's also where we see are
killed actually most wheat seeds are
killed below well below 55 um 131 even
at at 120 degrees Fahrenheits Mo most
wheat seeds can die um but if you want
to be sure um the higher the temperature
the better and and keeping the pile
moist during those hot temperatures also
helps to destroy some
seeds okay just as a clarification those
dips on this curve really you're to
represent one one pile maybe turned or
water it's an immediate loss temperature
but it
recovers okay and then there's a curing
stage at the end where uh the process
continues it's de decomposition is still
going on but it's at a much slower pace
so this curing pile doesn't require the
same
attention um or effort as the active
composting stage it's an important stage
a lot of things happen in curing
temperatures lower again those
mesophilic organisms fungi begin to come
back uh in greater numbers during curing
and
continue turning this partially
composted material into
compx so it's an important stage but
it's requires less attention and
actually less time
as so here are some of the key factors
that determine how well composting
occurs um it needs to be moist the
organisms live in in the moisture within
the compost pile and the 50 to 60%
moisture content um seems to be uh the
optimal it has to have a good mix of
nutrients particularly carbon and
nitrogen I recommend higher carbon
nitrogen
ratios um than most people do if go by
the book we're talking about 25 to one
or slightly larger I like to say more
because the more higher the carbon
nitrogen ratio is the better that a p
windro tends to aate and also this it
slows down a process bit as the carbon
nitrogen ratio raises above 25 to one
process slows down um if you're in a
hurry that's not good but if you're not
in a hurry and um want a little more
leeway to manage the process properly
having a higher C ratio isn't bad um
however the downside of high seeden
ratio is that carries over into the
compost making compost High ratio and
that that does have
some bulk density refers to um the
weight per unit volume um but is turns
out the bulk density is a pretty good
indicator of the processed conditions
generally both the
moisture um condition and how well how
much for space there is open for space
there is and so um it's a good indicator
of how well a pile will aate whether
you're using fans or passive variation
and should stay below 100 th a thousand
pounds
cub and and
temperatures um again try to stay in
that ideal range above where the pass
Hill but below where the microorgan
being seem to suffer and that seems to
be about
160 okay there's some other parameters
that are important but um they're not as
important in terms of control what we do
oxygen is clearly important but in most
cases composters do not spend a lot of
time measuring it they use temperature
as an indirect gauge
instead so let's take a look a little
bit more at each one of these again uh
there's there's a range where moist
where there moisture content is just
right you get a little higher it's too
wet materials get heavy pors get fill
with water it can't aate and then a
point where the process slows down
because there's n enough water for the
microorganisms to
inhabit uh so that sweet sweet spot is
is above 50 below 65 you get below 35
it's way too dry and nothing will happen
and it's thir
stu um so the challenge in composting is
depending upon where you're composting
where you are is keeping it moist in ARR
regions this is a constant strugle
because it's not easy to add moisture
evenly uh throughout a
pile a good way to do it is to add
moisture while you're turning um but
that means you've got to carry water
with with with along with you as you're
doing the
turn so keeping it moist is
important um keeping it dry keeping from
getting too moist is also important so
here's pictures of these fabric covers
that are used to keep out
precipitation this is not necessarily
the only way but it's a good picture of
um of an attempt to keep it from uh
getting too moist really the best way or
the most common way is to uh turn it to
try to drive off some of that moisture
especially on the sunny day um but in
some places keeping it from getting too
dry is the challenge in other places
keeping it from getting too
moist oxygen really is the key to
composting you know that's what the we
want aerobic oxygen rich conditions in
the pile because we want aerobic
microorganisms to do the work because
those are the ones who do it most
quickly most completely and with the
least amount of odors um 5% is
considered a minimum that's a big bare
minimum but generally the goal is to try
to keep it above
that and normally we don't monitor from
oxygen um again we let temperature tell
the story um and then we just array as
best we can um and oxygen is delivered
to the to the pile by Iration and
there's two primary ways of eration uh
windr and passive piles aate by passive
aration basically what's happening is
inside the pile it's a little warmer
than it is in the environment around and
that warm air uh leaves the
pile uh and then it creates a vacuum and
cool air cool oxygen rich air replaces
it uh diffusion is another way that
oxygen gets in and CO2 gets out of the
pile but defusion is a very slow process
relying on that doesn't provide nearly
as much air and oxygen as
these passive air movements and these
passive air movements are very dependent
on first of all generating temperatures
inside warmer temperatures inside but
also uh how easy the air can move in and
out and that has to do with the airspace
within the P both
density uh we can air with more
certainty by putting a fan and some duct
workor within the pile um using pressure
to blow air into the middle of it and
then hopefully it's distributed evenly
and the cool fresh oxygen rich air goes
in the middle cools the pile keeps it
from getting too hot and also brings in
oxygen the primary way of using Forest
Iration especially on Farm on farms it's
a method called the air rated static
pile method this would be a diagram of
that rated static piles do not get
turned on a regular basis um they may
get turned
occasionally um once or twice and the
Iration system has to be um taken out
disassembled and reassembled when when
returning uh or it's built into a floor
and you can turn on top of
that um but this is a picture of the AA
sta could also suck air out of the pile
change the direction of these arrows um
that would be used when we a little bit
more concerned about
odors um because you concentrate the
exhaust from the pile at one point and
that can be directed to an odor
treatment system like
pile but positive pressure uh systems
like the one showing here um are
generally easier to handle they use less
energy and um they are the most common
I'll show you some pictures of these
later okay so I haven't talked about
turning yet in regard to ation so what
does turning do well doesn't really aate
it at least not in the long term here
are the functions that turning it does
charge the pile with fresh air and
oxygen that oxygen is lasts only briefly
an hour maybe two hours at Best the
Turning is not really does not really
provide
irration what it does is it releases the
gases that are crapped inside mixes
things up so it redistributes nutrients
and moisture it breaks up air
channels improves
consistency in some cases it does fluff
so it reduces the density of the
material in the wind drill uh making it
easier for air to flow in and and out by
passive
variation but in other cases it doesn't
in other cases it shreds particles apart
and after turning you end up with a a
windo that's less dense than
so it depends on the situation and
turning brakes apart
comes so that's primarily what it does
and because of that generally
invigorates the process always see a
burst of activity
after part of it that oxygen that it
builds in for a short time but a lot of
it are those other you mixing and
churning um I kind of compare it to
making a stir fry on the stove and
you're actually doing the stirring to
distribute things around the pan a
little bit more and make things more
even that's the turning
point you can Envision what's going on
within the composting pile at a
microscopic level and it might look
something like this um you've got these
particles of biodegradable organic
materials um they're breaking down and
this moisture film kind of clings to the
edge of it and that's where the
microorganisms are in that moisture film
and they're breaking down the particle
from its surfaces outward and the
nutrients tend to dissolve into that
moisture film and the
microorganisms um gain the nutrients and
the
moisture um where's the oxygen well
immediately most of the oxygen in those
core spaces that you're seeing on the
left and it has the oxygen has to used
into the moisture film to get to the
microorganism um so it's important to
remain to maintain pile that has those
four spaces we call them free air spaces
because they're not filled with
motion um so that the oxy can first get
into the interior Pile in order to fuse
into the liquid film we want to avoid
the situation on the right as much as
possible where particles are clumped
together there's no free a space um and
no and it's more difficult for oxygen to
fuse into that moisture so we want to we
want to encourage the left hand side of
this diagram rather
than and what determines that in part is
the bulk density bulk density
reflects whether we have these particles
all packed together uh without free air
space and a lot of moisture or whether
it's
fluffier and so uh we shoot for a bulk
density in that's 700 to 1,000 pounds
per
cubic and it's pretty easy to measure bu
density all you need is a pale on the
scale there's a standard method of doing
this by filling a pale certain amount
dropping it from a certain height keep
filling the pil and keep dropping it
until you get to a certain point and
then you weigh it and You' got the
weight for a 5 gallon pale and you can
convert that to pounds go it's easy to
do the reason I show this slide is
because bulk density is an easy and and
very general measure to determine um the
conditions in the p and it's a good
one pile height it's often the question
uh what's the right height for a pile I
like to measure um pile Heights in
Calvin this is Calvin you see in the
picture this pile is maybe two Calvin
High the reason I measuring Calvin is
because to me feet is a bit too impris
we're talking about p height what's the
difference between a three foot high or
four foot high pile or
even six and eight foot high pile not
much so I like to refer to pile Heights
and Calin um and so in general maybe
three Calin is a Max and if you want to
do the conversion Calvin's about six
foot tall that's the point we don't need
to be to% size uh as one of my
colleagues says there's really no
decimal points in
compx um but in regard to windro size
maybe the best rule of thumb to go by is
you have to drive onto a
pile um to get it to the top to stack it
then it's too
big but generally the pile sizes are
determined by the equipment you're going
to be used to making cont you're using
wind Turner the wind returners are going
to dictate the power but if you're using
loaders you can go a lot higher and so
this rule of thumb of not driving on the
pile to determine the
pile the way to go next factor is feed
stocks feed stock all brings all of its
character to the compost pile and
basically feed stocks are what determine
how the composting process is going to
go how it's going to behave and feed
stocks primarily determine the character
of the compos itself so if you have
nutrient Rich feed stocks you'll make
nutrient Rich comp you have nutrient
poor feed stocks you'll make nutrient
poor
comp uh Woody feed stocks make Woody
comp you get
it and feed stocks with contaminants
will make comp you can do things to
improve that really it's the feed stops
that
determ sometimes you get feet stocks
that are adequately balanced or compost
without doing anything like these y
triming on the right sometimes not like
this manure in the bottom left um that
needs some amending before it'll compost
that and so what we do is we mix
ingredients together ingredients that
don't have enough nitrogen with Medi
ingredients have too much nitrogen
ingredients that are wet in with
ingredients that are dry to try to get
get these conditions I talked about
early and russan leaves and grass and
food are good examples in uh in the
backyard composting world we talk about
these low nitrogen materials as Browns
and these high nitrogen materials as
greens and the high nitrogen materials
most often are wet not always but most
often are wet and the the low nitrogen
materials most often are dry so
combining them together with the right
sedan ratio also tends to improve the
moisture that here's an example of a
composting
recipe um on a farm using fish waste
James mwe is going to talk about this a
lot more so I'm not going to go into it
there's examples of nitrogen Rich feet
stocks poultry manure fish waste food
grass and you want to combine those with
nitrogen poor feet stops like fall
leaves straw uh horse beding brush
things of that nature I cross out carbon
and put in nitrogen po because uh we
often refer to things as as carbon
sources but really carbons in everything
even in the
nitrogen High nitrogen materials
everything all organic material has
roughly the same amount of carbon it's
the nitrogen that
determines whether it's a carbon Source
or not
really okay the next factor is
temperature talked a lot about that
already um there's temperature range
that's ideal for composting it tends to
be between 120 and uh
um 140 degrees fahit but at 160 it
doesn't suffer much above 160 start to
suffer more but we want to get to that
130 level to kill pathogens and wheat
seeds Okay the thing about temperature
the most important thing about
temperature the composting process is
that you can consider temperature
composting Soma talked about this
already the release of heat is direct
result of the process so watching the
temperature reflects the release the
Heat and the microbial activ so it's the
most important parameter to monitor to
tell us what's going on and then time is
the last thing it takes some time you
can't really Rush the microorganism too
much usually we need at least about a
month to make stable compost for General
use um more often it takes two to six
months and if you relaxed about it or
have tough Fe stocks it could take a
year or
more and it depends on the beat stocks
how you intend to use the compost and
how stability stable it needs to be when
you're using it the
methods and it's really the
management once you determine it's it's
the management more so than the method
that determines what you
not and then you watch all these things
to make sure it's gone and the sensory
OB ation includes
OD okay let's move on to equipment and
methods I'm going to use examples to go
over different Farm scale
composting so the most common is turned
windr and that's what you'll see the
most pictures of and that's probably
what you have in your mind when you
think about comp a long narrow pile of
material that gets turned and churned
every now and then
the main advantage of Windrose is that
it's simple it's easily started and
managed anybody can do it anybody almost
build a window in their backyard Pile in
their backyard and start composting or
in their back
40 really don't need any special
equipment and that's the reason most
people so here's an example of a farm
who compost de cattle manure with some
waste from grocery stores and and some
from food processing facility or all
vegetables in that case and they simply
make window RS with um a skid steel
loader that has an oversized
bucket um makes the windows and turn
every now and then okay fairly simple
when the
turn that's really a a a composter
specific
situation uh and preference um but it
doesn't require much more than a skid
steer in this case um there are some
involve probably to move materials
around the farm but so this is all
involves here's another example this is
a horse
farm um that's using it adding its horse
minority yard trimmings um that it was
getting from the municipalities I don't
think this
operation I think it's closed down years
ago but basically just to show you how
they manage it they use an excavator as
their primary
uh turning device just every now and
then move piles with the bucket on an
excavator and I also use that to build
piles their their main objective here
was to compost the yard trimers um the
horse farm is basically just an excuse
to have an off farm when you're
composting your trimmings um you're
going to need to grind them up if you're
taking any brush and then because
there'll be a lot of wood still in it
when you're done composting you'll need
to screen out the oversized materials
and in this case they use the traal
screen that probably hired out both
sides of that they hired in the grinder
and hired out screen
time uh here's another example of a
windro u turned operation on in this
case the farm compost manure with the AR
jimes and also some food processing
waste um and and they turn they build
their windows with a loader and turn
them with this tractor power Turner like
tractor uh Powers the Turner both by
pulling it um it's used for travel and
also through the the
PTO uh it drives the Turner
itself and you can see they have fairly
wide aisles between wind grows to
accommodate the traffic on both sides
although um you could actually stack two
windows closer together you don't need
an aisle for the tractor on both
sides this is still that same form um
they do make an effort to water their
windr their windro Turner has nozzles on
it so they can add water while they're
turning and they have a tank wagon that
they pull behind the Turner um which
feeds the nozzles on the front because
they're handling our trimmings this uh
Farm also does some screening they own
the satellite screen they use to
make Dr rink yes just wanted to flag we
have about 20 minutes left 20 minutes 20
minutes for my part for the presentation
before okay to leave to leave time for
Q&A okay thank you Linda
um again this is another example of a
farm that uses a window Turner trctor
assisted windro Turner in this case it's
uh uh sparms and Idaho so their Dairy
manure is from the outside lots and it
tends to be dry um they add some bedding
to it to improve the the composting
situation and they have a their Turner
has needs a tractor for travel but it
has its own engine to power Turner
itself um they have a a to mounted Manor
spreader um that they build the piles
with
with um and because it's an Idaho
because the material starts out dry and
they get very little
precipitation um they add water
regularly and they use a tractor toi to
do that right after they do this it will
come through with the Turner and mix
that water into the
window okay so those are turn
systems um the other is areast static P
diagram that um atic piles more reliably
keep um the contents of the pile eroded
because we're forcing air into there it
also provides a level of temperature
control using that air um to cool down
the pot so you get more process control
with area St pot another important
advantage of it is you taking all these
material that might have been in a
windro and pulling them all together
into a wider higher pile so we have a
lower area reir that means if you need
to cover it it's more easily done
than and these advantages particularly
the low area
requirement um
have driven the conversion of a lot of
windr composting facilities on farms
included or a static
piles because it
hasn't but with a static piles you have
to add some um energy and
Engineering so it's still pretty simple
you have a a pipe which serves as an air
duct hooked to a blower with some
control mechanisms that Force air into
the pile these photos are from a
wastewater treatment plant that
composted biosolids but I could have
told you this from the farm and it would
have looked realistic this just could be
inside of a barn so it's still simple
enough we on our f um this particular uh
composter has very simple controls it's
an on and off timer so the timer spends
it some time on to aate the wind dra and
cool it off and some time off to let it
rest and do its thing and uh the timer
settings would be adjusted uh manually
based upon the temperatures for the
operator
same there are more compc Control
Systems where uh the blower might come
on and off based upon temperature
feedback there's on there's a
temperature sensor in the pile that
sends a signal to the controls and turns
the blowers on and off it's still fairly
simple and then they're very
sophisticated controls where the the fan
runs
continuously and the temperature sensor
turns the the air flow rate up and
down and this is that same application
so the the equipment they use are that
blower and um this loader to build piles
and take piles apart and then they have
a mixer which mixes in the biosolids and
the wood chip amendment that they use to
create the right Iration conditions the
right free air space and bulk density
for that
prod and this is just an an an augur
based Turner like many uh Turners on
Farm like many mixers excuse me this is
an augur based mixer like many on Farm
mixers that are used to mix feed
RS here's a a different version of an AR
static pile before we saw individual
piles this is called an extended piles
where each batch of material is built on
the side of another to extend the pile
and each batch is called cell and the
cell may have its own a irration pipe
and you can see here um one blower is
feeding numerous cells through a
manifold um so this is on a farm this is
a farm that used to compost by Windrose
and found the the advantages of an area
stat P will to
converge this Farm uses um a fairly
durable pipe it's highdensity
polyethylene pipe um as the duck work um
to avoid damaging the pipe
when breaking down the piles they
actually pull the pipe out using a
tractor and chain this is this is the
most common way of of running areas that
a piles map is with durable pipe that
gets pulled out before the piles get
broken down the other option is to have
a loader operator who's really good and
can avoid pipe as much as possible um
but more and more people are doing this
pipe BL me
okay here's another area static pile uh
again this is Farm they're composting
dewatered Dairy Manor solids and they
decided to build a building to house the
composting system and compost U the
solids in these
bunkers uh the bunkers have a positive
variation system in the floor uh I don't
recall whether the it has pipes on the
playing on the floor or narration system
that built into the floor um but uh
nevertheless it's positive airation
system air blowing up from the floor
these materials here's a picture of the
Iration systems on the bottom left the
blowers and the pipe that are feeding
each of these uh bunkers and each bunker
has their own system um that person
shining back in the light um he's not an
angel although to me he has his name is
Peter Moon he designed this system um
Peter is uh a very good fellow know
he he specializes in irated sta systems
and he do does a lot of his work on
farms helping Farms to uh make an area
static pile system fit into their
farming operation he's put a lot of
systems on farms um all over the country
and even outside the country in fact
this is is a Peter Moon uh design system
uh this is a farm that uh compost the
yard trimmings from the community and
its own Farm waste and it also gets some
waste from a hotel that it's associated
with um it's not a lot it's not a large
scale system um they do this uh under
cover in these bunkers uh in this
building each of these uh bins holds
batch uh there are bins on both sides of
the building
and so they have one two three they have
about uh 8 to 10 um of these base which
to work with uh when they're done in the
base U piles sit out and the material
sits in passive piles to cure so a
fairly simple system their arated system
looks like this um so you can see the
plum on the bottom
left um so the the air gets gets
delivered into this Plum it's covered
with the slatted
boards um air moves up through this the
um spacing between the boards and up
into the floor the floor is covered with
a layer of wood chip to keep Vines out
of the irration system and to help
distribute the air from the irration
plum pop through the materials and on
the right you see up um the shed the
blower shed uh where the pipes are
directly to the various uh um base and
also the control
system yeah fairly simple
controls uh here's another example of an
aerated static pile this one has a
little different twist uh for one thing
this is a negative variation
system um so this is continuous bed
of dairy cattle manure mostly from heers
and calves so it's fairly highly beded
it doesn't need need to be mixed with a
lot of amendment to have the right
quality composing and they just build
these in strips okay and then start
ating them the air gets pulled down
through the bed and this is what it
looks like underneath okay the aration
systems in the floor the floor is
covered with uh with wooden planks that
have poles drilled in it beneath the
wooden planks in is a trench the
narration pipe that occas occasionally
delivers or sucks air down through the
wooden planks and into U
manifold what's interesting about this
system is they use it for heat recovery
so here's the part we've seen at least
uh in the composting building air moves
down through the compost and then
there's a manifold that's the blowers on
the other side of the manifold that's
what's sucking the air through the
compost and then the blower Del the air
to this heat exchange um this is a a
bolt tank on one end and just a a large
conduit maybe a foot long of PVC pipe on
the other uh the hotar goes in the one
end where the conduit is as a gas
there's heat pipes in the middle heat
pipe has refrigerant in it that the
refrigerant evaporates on the hot end
and then um
condenses in the bulk tank where it gets
cooled down and heats the water in the
bulk tank and then that water is
delivered to uh floor for facility
heating um one Farm have you have used
this to heat floors on their calf beds
and you can pull off some hot water out
of this um several Farms are doing this
there's a a company called agrolab
Technologies based in Vermont that is
doing a lot of the Some Farms in New
England um they have since moved away
from this uh heat pipe type of heat
exchanger and develop others some that
you that they're starting to mount on
these skits that can be move from Farm
to farm so uh an interesting and
intriguing twist to compost just another
reason to compost is to recover that
heat not being done a lot but in some
places uh why
not
so the next method of composting would
be within this giant category called
contained or in vessel composting
systems where the composting environment
is closed within a container or vessel
some of these are being done on farms by
far uh it's mostly window RS and are
static piles but there are places for
these on certain farms under certain
conditions okay almost all of these
are require a second stage of composting
that is the vessel is only first part of
composting where it's most important to
have that
inment and almost all are situation
where company's selling this vessel to
you and they also support it but there's
at least one example and probably more
where it's homemade so this is a farm
build in closed arated box might it
might be called a tunnel or box
composting system in other places and in
this case it's handling dairy cattle and
you can see a picture of the inside on
the right there's positive varation in
the floor uh the air taken out the
headspace is Rec recirculated a bit fed
in with some fresh
air what this does give you is a just a
little bit more control both of odors
and the process I'm not sure on a farm
this is Justus
um but this farmer um felt that he could
pull it off by building it himself and
he also wanted to recover the heat so
there's some heat tubes in the top of
this vessel in the top of this tunnel
that are just circulating air through
the composting space circulating water
through the composting space and picking
up some heat and using it to u to feed
this uh radiator that blows warm air
into their shop across the way so just
another
example um this is less than an example
and just a point that these types of
invest systems are called agitated Bays
they're like windr only they have solid
walls and there's an automatic Turner
that runs through um without an
operator that turn the material in these
bays and also move it along doesn't just
turn the material in place tends to pick
it up and shift it so there's a material
handling advantages here here most of
these when they're on
farms are um used for poultry minor
because um poul is a little more
difficult to compost because of the odor
and high nitrogen content um and many
cases it's not mended with with low
nitrogen so some a lot of this is
targeted here's a commercial system um
okay it's called an earth system by the
Green Mountain Technologies company um
this is a small
scale could call an agitated Bay or an
agitated vessel but um it's one of its
Target uses is on hor Stables who have
um hor Bing that they want to turn into
compost and this can be done on
site drums uh drums are another type of
invest system uh key thing about drums
it's a very short compost most drums
handle material from 3 to six days and
then it goes out and the advantage of
the drum is it gets the process going
quickly and it contains the material
when it's most odorous okay so here's
four examples all but the one on the
upper right hand side are on farms the
one on the upper right hand side is at a
college but again it could be a farm uh
and so they put the materials through
quickly and then stack them in windr or
piles or area static piles to finish the
composting except the one on the bottom
left really is just recycling manure
beded manure to recover the bedding and
re so these drums are used in a lot of
cases for that but there're another
legitimate invest system for
CLS how am I doing on time now
Lind um we've got like six minutes left
six minutes okay let's talk quickly
about the site um the characteristics of
a site so here's a farm the farmsteads
up top that that hypothetical situation
is looking
to um to compost on site and they're
kind of identified this piece of land as
a potential compost area so what do we
need to know to see if this is a a a
legitimate site a feasible site or not
well we've got to look at a couple
things about the site is the land slope
uh which way does water flow uh when it
falls on the site in this case there's
sort of compound slope down in in each
of these directions right so it' be
straight down
diagonally um other features of the site
that you need to identify which
direction is the prevailing wind I
don't I don't put too much importance in
prevailing wind direction in most cases
because the wind changes so much in
almost every site it glows from every
direction um often enough that
prevailing wind isn't a good predictor
where odors are going to go most of the
time but still it's good to know there's
a creek near the site that's important
because we can't be too close to that
residences very important because that
might be uh oder impacts there and we
want to know the distances from these
things there are regulations that
determine how far at a minimum you need
to be from these things I can tell you
those
minimum separation distances between a
composting site and residence they're
not enough to um prevent odor impacts to
those resen you need to have good
management as well but these are some of
the things you need to identify where's
the water which way is the lands slope
where are the residences and other other
people that might be impacted where's
the wind
so this particular Creek is about 300 ft
from the edge of the composting site
that's not bad most regulations would
say that's within
limits it would be
buildable um there's a gravel road
access to a composing site is important
in this case there's a gravel road that
connects the comple site to The
Farmstead which is where the materials
going to come from Mostly Manor so
that's another important feature of the
site um so when you identify where you
going to do the things on your site
based upon this uh I might mention on
this particular site um I might
discourage this composter from from
choosing this site largely because not
how far the residences are from the site
but because few of them are directly
downhill so on on a cold clear night
where you get a temperature inversion
and not much wind um you get the
condition where air from a composing
site that might that might be on a hill
or Plateau as this one is would drain
down downhill um and collect in low
areas and cause odor that way this
particular site is susceptible to that
because of where the residents are uh
and the the cold perhaps odorous air
could collect in that
uh in that stream gra so then you can
look a little closer and decide what you
can do and where you can put things uh
and then from these Circle diagrams
which is our way to start you can start
doing a more detailed design maybe to
scale but those are the features of the
site again water is going to be
important um increasingly important
because water that runs off the working
areas is fairly heavily polluted um it
has a lot of solids in it that um and so
runoff carries a lot of organic matter
has a high bod level and could um become
odorous over time so what you want to do
is first of all you want to
keep clean runoff that would tend to run
onto the site from running onto the site
you want to divert it around the site
and that's what these features circled
in blue are they're dkes or BMS and
channels that are are intercepting the
run on in this case in diverting it
around the site and then you want to
keep the water that does fall on the
site on the site by collecting it and
then concentrating it or treating it if
NE necessary and so you would put it in
a pond or an infiltration area never
directly into a stream because it's
fairly strong in organic so you need to
capture it contain it treat it if
necessary reuse it that's the best way
to do it um but need to control water on
the
site as I said earlier most of the
strength of the water is in its um is in
a sediment that it carries so an easy
way to improve the quality of the runoff
water is to get sediment out and that's
fairly easy you can use compul filter
socks that are shown in uper right hand
corner or filter BMS of compost or wood
chips uh or actually a constructed
sediment basin to do that but it's
better to keep that if you're storing
water in a pond it's better to to take
out the the siment before it goes to the
pond so the pond does itself doesn't get
motus uh common question is you need a
paveed site and I would say really for
for sure only if the regulations require
it that's rarely required Farm
situations but it might be some cases
and if regulations don't require it then
probably you don't need PVE site but
it's an advantage to have one um so even
though it might be costly uh it can be
worthwhile for instance in this picture
this is you know what happens in in the
spring when the snow melts around the
site at least on a day like today um
this operation could work they have an
an asphalt
path okay
odor odor is going to be a problem
there's a lot of things that can do um
when composting generates odors because
materials decompose the composting SE
it's it's inherent connection
decomposition odors are going
to but you don't necessarily have an
odor problem you don't have an odor
problem till the odors are
emitted um and then they travel to
someone who's G to to
OBC so there are several stages in an
odor in the atomy of an odor problem
where composting facility can
intervene um to lessen that odor and
make it acceptable to the neighborhood
and
Community um and one of those is
befriending the community and others are
more um operational on the compost
side okay so here are some odor
management uh practices I'll call it the
greatest hits isolated site is the best
thing you can
have keep from overloading the site with
the organic materials because the more
organic the more materials there are on
the site that can generate odor the
stronger the going to be contain or
enclose odor sources if necessary but
then there are there are simpler U
measures like prompt handling of feed
stocks follow good composting practices
maintain
grocy um CDN ratio moisture Contour
where there should be and
air a few more Ely turning watch when
you turn not just how often but turn
only when needed because when turning is
done it's a quick intense release of
odors uh one of my favorite oor control
measures uh certainly uh well Su to F is
you use a bio cover okay the bio cover
is nothing other than a layer on top of
a pile or window that's generating odors
it's a layer of material
uh mostly compost or pre compost before
it's screen that still has some Woody
material in it and you just put it on
top and it's simple containment and what
happens is the air moving up through the
top of the pile is it is absorbed and
water is condensed in this layer and
much of the odor is contained not all of
it and broken down in this layer so a
very simple uh underused method of Odor
Control
so I know I went through all that kind
of fast um six minutes is probably up if
you want more
information uh The Institute for local
self reliance is having
uh it's webinar and I believe they also
have an online course that you can take
to learn more about it I teach um with
uh my partner Matt cotton of foundations
of Composting class it's a one-day class
we teach this at the beginning of the US
composting Council conference every year
uh this year it's in Austin um and I'm
sure we'll be teaching on January fourth
that mass man there is Matt um teaching
if you want even more training um there
were a number of multi-day Hands-On
training programs around uh Maine has
had one for a long time I don't know
when they're starting theirs up again
but the US compost or excuse me the
compost research and Education
Foundation runs a five-day
course um around different parts of the
country um and it's been fairly popular
here's an idea of the
curriculum um for you to get some
Hands-On training if you'd like uh the
composting facility tours are
particularly good that's why I
highlighted okay I think I made it
within time so thank you very much I
apologize for rushing through this um
but that's the time we have and
hopefully I can answer unanswered
questions for you
now yes exactly that is what we are
going to do so thank you Dr rink for a
great presentation um we have been
collecting some questions as they've
been coming in um so starting with a um
clarification on the hot stage of
composting the graph that you showed uh
indicated it might take 1 to n months
for the active composting phase um but
the person usually hears two to three
weeks during that phase before before it
moves into finishing or curing any
comments on
that if if you have an A A A close to
ideal
process um you can do that in two to
three weeks um you can you can make
compost that is ready to move into the
curing phase with an ideal process and
suitable feed stocks but in my
experience uh in order to get Most Feed
stocks to the point where it can go to a
curing pile and should be piled without
turning takes a lot longer than three
excuse me three weeks more like two
months at a minimum again it depends
upon the feed stocks slowly composting
feed stocks feed stocks that may have
gone through some decom some uh
stabilization already it could work for
example um the standard method for
composting
biosolids um which was developed by the
USDA at the Belville research station
sometimes it's called the Bel aat static
pile
method typically recommended composting
under ation for three weeks and then go
to curing for a month bio first of all
biosolids has already been through
aerobic digestion process so it's
partially stab but even then I don't
think
biosolids can be stabilized in three
weeks I think it needs longer that's my
personal feeling I think if you're going
for three weeks you're rushing it but if
you're doing that you need an ideal
process certainly for a
station
uh uh a fairly large amount of bulking
agent that allows the Iration to be uh
evenly
distributed
um and um the right seat end ratio and
so on I think three weeks
push that's great and that actually
leads into another question how do you
recommend getting good free
airspace um the best way to get free air
space is to mix the materials to a bulk
density uh of less than a th000 pounds
per cubic yard by
adding dry bulking materials wood chips
would
be um the best is usually the best
choice because they're chunky they have
good structure they stand up in a pile
um they don't compress they don't glose
or structure as they
decompose um in fact they go through the
composting process almost unchanged and
if you're not using them for mulch um
you would end up screening them out wi
chips are the best amendment of pick to
mix with other materials to get that
three a space don't have wood chips you
can do it with other bulky materials
like corn cops would be great peanut
hols would be great um chop straw um
even sawdust but if if you use sawdust
you're going have to use a lot of it and
probably dry the material out too much
more and then add water back um the
chunk of your material about which of
stand
uh there's a question about whether you
can make good compost using a large
static pile that doesn't get turned much
um and is also not actively
arated yes you can make good compost in
a large static pile um some people make
good compost in very large static piles
um I use the term massive passive for
those
um so what you have to do in that case
is
weight um the key to making compost when
the conditions aren't good so like in a
large pile that isn't AED much um is a
weit for time to do its work so I I
showed that picture where uh passively
irrated piles heat up inside and that's
the main way to aate well in large piles
if there's not a great deal of air flow
through that thermal effect then you're
relying on diffusion and it's going to
take diffusion a while for that oxygen
to creep into the the pile and uh and
the organisms to uh decompose the
material so yeah you can use a large
pile
um and you just have to take longer to
do it that in itself is not a problem
the problem with large piles and waiting
for them is that it um greatly increases
the risk of spontaneous combustion
occurring in the pile for that reason I
don't recommend it um but I can pretty
much say that if you have a large pile
of actively decomposing material and you
leave it in place without moving it in
within a month or two um you're going to
get fire and that could be serious so
although yes you can make compost in
large piles without Force variation um
you're increasing the risk of
fire great okay and then uh question
about the Biol layer and whether six in
say something like six inches of wet
straw would work as a Biol layer or any
other recommendations for easily
removable materials to use as a biolayer
well once you're making compost you'll
have compost at your disposal to use as
a biolayer and that's the best one um
it's better if the compost has some
paracity to it that will
allow the the passive air movement that
is already curring to to to continue on
through the
biolayer um but just finished compost
will work and a 6 inch six four to six
inch layer will do of that um if you if
you have a screen and Screen overs will
work pretty
well um my next suggestion would be a
mixture of compost and wood chips um
next after that would be just wood chips
uh straw would work the problem with
straw is is it t it becomes matted down
when it gets wet and it can become a
barrier
irration um so that would be the problem
with straw but I think as a containment
me mechanism it would it would contain
odors it would just um make the Iration
condition within the pile chop straw
with be better than
UNS awesome thank you for all those
options uh and the last question that
I'm going to ask before we do some final
polling and close things up uh I think
is an important one it's about uh curing
is always
discussed um as an important phase of
composting but what's the actual
downside if any of spreading a pile of
on the field that is not completely
cured
um the downside of spreading material
that is not completely C is that
um it has it still has um some compounds
the compost still has some compounds um
that are phytotoxic that that would hurt
hurt the plants but if you're merely
spreading compost on top of a of a um a
field let's say during the fall or
winter or um onto a fow field uh it
shouldn't be a problem so so um that's
where I said the intended use of the C
post is important in fact if you're
spreading compost on the field um Navy
stability is not that important all and
you can cut it short you don't even have
to cure it uh depends entirely on its
use if you're putting compost into a
potting media it has to be very stable
if you're incorporating compost into a
garden it has to be fairly stable but
spreading it on a field especially when
um the field is not growing anything at
the moment fine go ahead and do it
saving yourself time and
money awesome so I'm gonna call it there
with the questions but thank you all for
submitting them and um I hope that some
of the other ones that you all submitted
will be answered in F future sessions uh
but before we go uh just a few more
quick polls
first one being as an
overview of the fundamentals of on Farm
composting this webinar had too much
information the right amount of
information or not enough
information giveing you all just a few
more
seconds all righty it's always good to
see this that a vast majority say the
right amount of information so thank you
Dr rink for doing that um next
question uh are there any questions that
this presentation that were not answered
by this presentation any questions you
had about on Farm composting
fundamentals I realized that it often
take some time to digest this
information before you realize what
questions you still have so hopefully um
yall will get some answered in future
sessions as
well okay couple more
seconds so we're pretty e pretty split
um but majority says no great uh we are
considering doing like a live Q&A at
some point um if that's of Interest let
us know and invited back some of the
presenters from the series so let us
know if that's of Interest final
question um do you plan to participate
in any of the other webinars in this
series yes no
maybe just a couple more
seconds all right vast majority says yes
say yes that's fa fabulous for us to
know and we're so glad uh the series is
designed to sort of build over time um
and hopefully we'll get to answer all of
those questions the burning questions
you have about on Farm composting and
compost use so thank you so much Dr rink
uh for your great presentation and thank
you all for participating and we'll look
forward to seeing you at the next
webinar okay thank you all